vous ne valez bien pas c'est cool ça
merci à vous avez chauffer le l'espace
voilà je suis un artiste peintre et je
travaille pour une marque de bière
c'est marrant je vais vous expliquer ça
veut dire hors la loi je peux pas la
citer le château voilà pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas il ya une semaine
j'avais rendez vous avec le nouveau
responsable de la marque
donc c'est un rendez vous un peu
confidentiel pour lui expliquer
expliquer un peu quelle était la
relation qu'on avait avec la marque
comment on avait collaboré pendant 20
ans et qu'elle est notre manière quel
était notre manière de nous positionner
donc il m'a dit est ce que vous répondez
à débrief le schéma classique des voix
la démarque fluides non non nous on
répond pas débrief on a besoin de se
rencontrer en dehors des bureaux en
d'autres endroits échanger et qu'à un
moment où on fasse des choses voilà
importantes pour les gens ont soit voilà
qu'on fasse dès qu'on soit pas dans
quelque chose de fermé mais quelque
chose d'ouvert qu'on apporte et que nous
en tant qu'artiste on as besoin et on a
utilisé la marque pour communiquer des
choses aux gens pour aller vers les gens
rentré dans le système pour amener des
choses aux gens ça c'est vraiment
vraiment important parce qu'autrement je
préfère rester dans mon atelier
plutôt que d'aller perdre du temps avec
des gens qui ne comprennent rien et qui
ne sont pas ouverts aux autres
donc voilà pour dire qu' il faut
toujours rester dans ce qu'on est et
dans son voile a dans son métier de
peintre
alors là je vais vous poser une question
qui dessinaient quand il était petit
vous pouvez lever la main à tout le
monde
ouais c'est un peu une écriture
universelle la première écriture
et qui dessina aujourd'hui encore il ya
du monde quand même c'est super ça fait
plaisir
bah voila moi comme vous j'ai pas arrêté
de dessiner j'ai eu la chance de ne pas
arrêté de dessiner
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir un père qui
peignait quand j'étais enfant c'est
peut-être pour ça que justement j'ai
voulu en faire mon métier
il peignait mais gagner pas sa vie avec
donc j'ai voulu prouver que c'est un
métier qu'on pouvait gagner sa vie avec
alors c'est assez marrant parce que
encore aujourd'hui quand je rencontre
des gens ils disent quel est ton métier
je dis bah peintre les gens me disent
mais tu gagnes ta vie donc c'est
terrible on est face à à quelque chose
de terrible et durant ma scolarité ça a
été très difficile parce que moi j'avais
ce truc là c'était mon moyen de
m'exprimer c'est un bon moyen de
communiquer avec l'autre moi je n'arrive
pas à écrire ça a été très dur
d'ailleurs d'écrire des choses et et
voilà je ne comprenais pas pourquoi
l'école à un moment ne me poussait pas
ça comme j'étais bon à l'époque des rois
et alors tu vas faire des maths tu vas
faire d'économie tu vas rentrer dans le
système et moi j'avais pas envie de
rentrer dans le système
j'avais envie de faire ce que j'avais
envie de faire et ça c'est
catastrophique je pense que l'école doit
amener des gens à se trouver à voile à
trouver quelle est leur passion pour
qu'ils puissent être dans leur vie et
pouvoir faire ce qui leur ce qui leur
plaît c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
important j'ai eu la chance après un peu
plus âgées vers 16-17 ans de travailler
à l'hôpital de garches hôpital de
garches
voilà c'est un endroit où où des enfants
sont là et ont été touchées par des
parts des maladies graves et les gens
bizarres à ce génial c'est super tu tu
aide les gens mais je dis moi j'aide
personne je suis dans les changes dire
que je suis dans voilà dans le rapport à
l'autre et dans ce que l'autre peut
m'apporter
voilà moi je suis juste là dans
l'humilité et à ce que m'ont apporté ses
enfants c'est de la fois qu'ils avaient
en la vie cette force qu'ils avaient en
la vie et voilà moi j'avais mes deux
jambes je respirais et je file mais
c'est pas possible que je passe à côté
de ma vie il faut que j'aille là où je
dois aller c'est important
et puis j'ai eu la chance encore une
fois 2
rencontre et ned qui est un ami que j'ai
connu en quatrième et on avait les mêmes
envies on était très différent on avait
la même envie de peindre et on a fait
une école de graphisme et on a rencontré
jerk qui était voilà quelqu'un d'un peu
à part et puis on avait quelque chose de
fort tous les trois on avait cette envie
de peindre le graphisme ne correspondait
pas dans corps cette rébellion face au
système scolaire qui nous correspondait
pas et on s'est dit on va on va créer un
collectif
donc on a créé le collectif 9e concept
en 1990 c'était le nom d'une bd qui
avait écrit ned et puis à ce moment là
les galeries le milieu de l'art boulet
qu'on fasse d un style des installations
vidéo de la photo est dans le conceptuel
mais nous c'était un autre truc j'ai
aucun souci avec la photo et la vidéo
mais nous on avait envie de peindre mais
voilà les gens ne voulaient pas qu'on
expose donc on s'est dit bon bah faut
qu'on trouve d'autres solutions donc là
on a édité des autocollants qu'on a
collé un peu partout dans paris
c'est marrant on en a on a fait plus de
700 modèles aujourd'hui c'est un support
qui nous a toujours accompagné puisque
c'est un support qu'on peut donner aux
gens qu'on peut échanger et que les gens
se l'approprient et en font ce qu'ils
veulent et grâce à ces autocollants on a
rencontré une personne importante à
l'époque à paris qui s'appelle mike
sylla un sénégalais qui était vraiment
une figure de la de l'activisme en deux
grandes parisien et lui il a eu l'idée
de récupérer des vêtements des vêtements
des années 70 et de les faire repeindre
par des artistes
on a fait plus de 600 pièces ça a été
pour nous un exercice extraordinaire et
on était dans l'art en mouvement la
reporter par les gens pas juste voilà je
fais un tableau je reste dans mon
atelier on était dans quelque chose
d'interactif et ça a été très important
parce que il nous a fait comprendre que
pour y arriver et se développer en
collectif il fallait développer une
économie de la ned a eu l'idée d' à la
suite des vêtements de dessiner sur le
corse était lié à son style parce qu'il
avait un style très épique liées à ses
origines bretonnes
voilà celtique et il a eu l'idée de
dessiner sur les gens mais nous on
voulait que ce soit gratuit pour les
gens on voulait pas les faire payer
et à l'époque à la loi evin qui est
passé et les halles collier avec le
droit de communiquer la même manière
qu'avant donc ils avaient des budgets
pour d'autres choses on s'est retrouvé à
faire des tournées dans toute la france
donc on s'est retrouvé au bout de deux
ans avec plus de 600 date donc on a
embauché nos copains ça a été
extraordinaire ça nous a permis de
développer notre stylistique et puis
aussi à l'époque avait pas internet
il n'y avait pas tous à tous ces réseaux
et donc de toucher un peu ce qui était
notre notre pays comme on les gens
fonctionner dans un certain milieu les
bars et les boîtes de nuit
c'était assez intéressant et à l'époque
on a rencontré cette fameuse marque donc
je vous parlais au début et elle est au
bout d'un an de travail avec eux ont
tourné le pdg nous dit voilà je vous
donne temps et vous faites ce que vous
voulez en parallèle des agences qui
était juste dingue quoi à l'époque
c'était fou et on a continué à
développer les tournées on a monté des
tournées incroyable on a on a mélangé
les la danse hip hop le bmx l'art urbain
on a voilà les dj on avait les moyens de
le faire et de pouvoir le faire à partir
de là on a travaillé aussi sur d'autres
concepts on voulait parce qu'on sait
partie de cette culture cette culture de
la glisse
on voulait que les gens puissent visiter
une expo en skate qu'on a lancé l'ex
powell command board où les gens
pouvaient visiter l'expo c'était génial
ça permettait un petit peu de vivre une
exposition d'une autre manière
à partir de là on a monté une autre idée
parce qu'on a toujours eu envie d'avoir
des idées pour les partager avec les
gens on a monté le labyrinthe
alors ça ce qui était marrant c'est que
on voulait amener la salle d'expo chez
les gens donc là on l'a mené au bord de
la mer et les gens pouvaient visiter
l'expo en allant à la plage pendant une
semaine
sauf qu'on à inverser le processus de
création c'est à dire que les gens
pouvaient voir les artistes travailler
et au moment où les artistes avaient
terminé de travailler ont démonté tout
donc les gens pouvaient rentrer dans
l'atelier parce que c'est dur de rentrer
dans un atelier d'artiste voilà et puis
de ce fait plein de marques on commence
à nous approcher nous
on voulait pas travailler avec des
marques et faire n'importe quoi donc à
un moment on dit voilà nous on veut
faire ça si vous voulez pas faire ça
c'est pas la peine donc nous on avait
des rêves
on avait des envies on a fait avec la
marque despé des bouteilles collector
c'était incroyable on a fait les
vitrines des grands magasins
ça c'était hyper intéressant j'ai une
anecdote d'ailleurs assez assez chouette
ou un monsieur d'un certain âge pas à
ces nouveaux afin dans la vitrine il dit
c'est fou moi j'ai toujours rêvé de
faire de la peinture mais ça m'a voilà
je mets pp parents voulu que je fasse
autre chose et aujourd'hui je me suis
remis et de vous voir peindre c'est
fantastique pour moi donc on a travaillé
avec plein plein de marques et grâce à
l'argent qu'on a récolté on a pu monter
des voix là d un autre concept un
concept purement artistique et on a
commencé à travailler sur la feuille de
sécurité sociale et le pansement
on a collé un peu partout dans la ville
et c'était intéressant ce que comme le
collectif brandissaient les gens
pouvaient s'exprimer sur ces feuilles et
ses pansements c'est un support commun à
tous et l'idée c'était de penser la
ville avec des images et surtout
démultiplier les images pas année
toujours la même image et reproduire un
logo dans la rue nous on était déjà dans
les marques et on voulait faire bouger à
l'intérieur c'était pas pour reproduire
dans notre milieu artistique
un logo et que les gens à un moment on
s'identifie juste à un logotype et puis
toujours dans l'idée de création on a
voulu intervenir dans la rue d'une autre
façon avec les étiquettes et les
étiquettes c'est intéressant ce que
c'est un support qu'ils ne marquent pas
qu'ils n'abîment pas l'espace et on a
joué sur le rapport aux prix honda no
choses et aux images qu'on donnait aux
gens parce que nous on les produisait
mais on les offrait aux gens il y avait
toujours une étiquette vierge les gens
pouvaient s'exprimer aussi pour
travailler avec nous voilà on a eu des
idées aussi lié à la musique parce qu'on
avait nos copains dj et nous on était
toujours dans les soirées à côté on s'y
tient faut qu'on monte quelque chose ou
un moment on soit tous ensemble public
puisse monter sur scène et que nous on
puisse dessiner donc le concept de que
que l'on voit là c'est que le dj prend
un disque il ne sait pas ce qu'il a joué
le public monte sur scène le customiser
avec des stickers après l'artiste
dessine et les gens repartent avec une
oeuvre originale chez eux gratuitement
parce que ça aussi on se l'est fait
financer pour que ce soit gratuit pour
les gens après on est des passionnés de
vinyles des résistants aujourd'hui c'est
marrant parce que ça revient à la mode
et voilà on a invité des copains a passé
neuf vinyle dans notre atelier puis on a
fait des podcasts grâce au nouveau
système aujourd'hui on peut diffuser des
choses et voilà c'est l'accessibilité
gratuite à autre chose donc c'est la
plupart sont des passionnés de vinyle
vont les récupérer donc cédé pas
forcément des morceaux qu'on entend
partout
donc il ya des gens connus moins connus
qui viennent voilà et puis à la suite de
ça on a monté une autre idée le scratch
peppers qui était aussi lié à
l'évolution technologique on pouvait
imprimés sur des grands papiers à des
prix raisonnables et l'idée c'était
voilà de superposer les choses d'un
hommage à jacques villeglé qui était un
artiste qui déchirait les intérêts des
affiches publicitaires et on a créé un
concept collectif et interactif où les
gens aussi interviennent on a aussi créé
avec ce concept des expositions c'est
les gens déchirant qui crée l exposition
de la le centre pompidou en voyant
l'activité qu'on avait et tous les
projets qu'on a monté voilà nous a dit
venez faire une expo centre où c'était
un truc incroyable parce que moi gamin
j'avais dit j'avais dit à mes copains un
jour on fera le centre pompidou voilà
c'est important le fera et puis là c'est
arrivé donc on a mis notre atelier dans
le sens pendant trois mois et on a créé
des espaces interactifs où les gens
peuvent dessiner autour de notre tableau
à la craie et voilà c'était fantastique
le soir on s'asseyait on regardait
c'était dingue
c'était plus baup nos tableaux ans qui
était fait c'était magnifique
voilà tout ça pour vous parler de la
chance que j'ai de travailler en
collectif
voilà deux sets de ce bonheur un moment
de se critiquer de la difficulté aussi
parce qu'il faut apprendre à se
connaître
il faut apprendre à respecter l'autre ou
en tant que leader j'ai été amené à
faire un travail sur moi pour ne pas
apposer ma vision aux autres mes
névroses pour toujours voilà montrer
qu'on est tous différent mois voilà je
menais les projets mais je n'étais pas
mieux que la personne derrière qui
mettait les choses en place on est tous
différents et on a tous des choses à sa
portée y'a pas de supériorité on est sur
un niveau
l'apa pyramidale et la peinture
comment dire ça a toujours été pour moi
mon bon moyen d'être en connexion avec
la vie des taux nets avec la vie voilà
de toujours chercher d'être dans
difficulté donc j'ai travaillé sur des
portraits pour comprendre l'autre et
aussi parce que petit je me disais rage
ne sait pas dessiner
donc j'ai voulu j'ai développé une
technique très précise pour prouver que
je savais dessiner mais ce qui
m'intéressait le plus derrière c'était
d'aller à la rencontre de deux d'autres
d'autres personnes d'autres cultures une
autre vision de la vie et j'ai dessiné
beaucoup à partir de photos
anthropologique pour leur redonner une
nouvelle vie dans l'espace urbain pour
montrer qu'à un moment on est là avec
notre système est qu'il ya d'autre
systèmes d'autres systèmes de croyances
de tout système de religieux sans parler
de religion mais de voilà de
spiritualité qui sont importants qu'on a
annulé on en imposant une vision et
qu'il faut s'en nourrir et voilà s'en
imprégner
et puis après le centre pompidou notre
milieu de milieux qu'on appelle de l'art
urbain s'est développée et le marché a
commencé à s'y intéresser et g voilà moi
j'ai jamais fait ça pour pour gagner
plein d'argent je fais juste là pour
faire mon métier est juste gagner ma vie
pour faire ce que j'ai à faire et j'ai
vu la manière dont le don le marché
fonctionner j'ai été dégoûté donc je me
suis dit je vais arrêter de peindre
parce que ça me correspond pas on ne
veut pas évoluer dans ce milieu là
et du coup j'ai décidé de monter que des
concepts collectif est d'observer les
gens et là on a monté une idée qui
s'appelle le graffiti collectif on a
laisser les gens s'exprimer et ça s'est
fait dans le cadre du festival black and
basque monté par moustiques avec qui on
a travaillé sur groland pendant sept ans
et sa femme christelle un festival
incroyable plein de bienveillance et
puis voilà les gens commencent à
dessiner des enfants les adultes mais
dans dans la voilà en étant décomplexée
c'est à dire en lâchant les choses et
pas en étant de regarder ce que je fais
ces gosses que je décide et
justement il faut lâcher les choses et
puis les choses se superposent et là on
arrive à quelque chose de puissant et ça
a été j'ai été émue j'étais la géniale
je suis heureux de vivre ça et puis la
file de christelle qui artistes
maintenant qu'il était pas qui était à
l'époque qui en a fait son métier me dis
bah va dessiner
et puis là givre annoncé c'est super
comme ça et puis à minova on va dessiner
je dis bon allez j'y vais je dessine et
alors là ça a été la révélation
ça a été énorme c'est à dire que c'est
un moment c'est fou dans la lys à un
moment quand on lâche prise que les
choses se passent et là ça a été
voilà l'explosion aujourd'hui je ne sais
pas ce que je fais voilà mais je sais
que je dois le faire voilà c'est c'est
voilà je suis rentré dans quelque chose
de très fort de très puissant qui vient
de voile à des profondeurs je sais pas
d'où ça vient mais et puis j'ai eu la
chance balle à au moins de mars de
partir en inde un matelot de ganges
c'est pour un projet qui s'appelle are
for tibet donc je suis aller peindre
dans le village du dalaï lama à la
rencontre du peuple tibétain en exil
et puis je commence à peindre et puis
tout de suite on nous a invités dans un
atelier l'atelier des maîtres temps qu'a
donc les maîtres temps casser des
peintres là en l'occurrence ils sont en
exil et tu rentres dans l'atelier tu
prends une claque au niveau technique
donc tu as 30 mètres qui travaille et
c'est des pièces qui sont réalisés de 1
à 3 ans déjà la tombola
la temporalité change et puis son une
balade c'est d'une précision dont tu es
dans l'humidité tu rentres là tu te dis
mais quel bonheur est là ils sont là
pour témoigner de leur histoire
donc il ya un sens profond à leur
travail et moi je me sens en accord avec
ça parce que j'avais peur d'aller
prendre là bas je me suis il faut que je
ressente les choses et puis voilà je
continue à faire mon mur et là le maître
temps car le grand maître en cas vient
me voir et me dit qu'il est ma peinture
qui la ressent il me tape dans le dos
alors c'est un peu violent mais ça a été
le puissant
alors je sais pas ce qui m'a fait passer
mais il m'a fait passer quelque chose
d'important
voilà tout ça pour vous dire que bas
tout ce parcours là aujourd'hui je
prends conscience et j'ai pris
conscience que je le dois à l'âme et
parents à la confiance qu'ils m'ont
donnée dire que ça ça n'a pas de prix
cette confiance là c'est quelque chose
de des normes on doit faire confiance à
ses enfants doit leur permettre d'aller
là où ils doivent aller et voilà celui
remercie et je les aime voilà ils m'ont
fait un cadeau une immense et puis il ya
très peu de temps je vis un bouquin et
puis je vois que le mot métier veut dire
mission de vie mission de vie et moi
j'ai toujours eu l'impression d'être
dans ma mission vie et voilà je trouve
que on doit tous à un moment trouver
quel est notre mission vis et une belle
définition du mot métier c'est sa vraie
définition on l'a trompé et qu'il faut
se trouver pour aller là on doit aller
qu'il n'ya pas de sot métier qu'on a
tous on est tous des artistes qu'on a
tous des choses à faire qu'on doit
exprimer notre très vite et créativité
dans ce qu'on fait on est tous
différents et qu'on doit tous travailler
est-ce qu'on est pour apporter à l'autre
pas pour nourrir son est beau voilà je
vais vous parler d'un des derniers
projets qu'on a monté qui s'appelle les
francos l'heure c'est un projet
collectif et c'est toujours la marque
dont je vous parlais avec laquelle on
travaille depuis 20 ans qui la financent
et et acheter des oeuvres à chaque
artiste ses oeuvres aujourd'hui fonds
sont rentrés dans le fond de la marque
et le personnel de la marque peut les
avoir chez chez eux
donc ça je suis hyper content et puis
voilà on essaye avec ce projet de créer
une peau humaine et que chacun dans son
individualité puisse s'exprimer
et que ensemble ça crée quelque chose et
donc on a des pochettes d'autocollants
toujours l'autocollant qui nous a suivis
on donne aux gens c'est gratuit donc le
système pay pour que ça soit gratuit
pour les gens mais il n'apparaît la
marque n'apparaît nulle part
et ça c'est important et puis on a
rencontré louis qui est un directeur de
création travaille pour une agence
digitale et puis voilà ils ont créé des
gouttes en réalité augmentée je sais pas
si vous avez vu le petit message mais en
fait il est une application
et voilà on peut alors là vous allez
savoir si vous l'avez télécharger vous
allez pouvoir voir ou revoir après en
sortant voilà où on est
sur de la réalité augmentée voilà comme
quoi on peut toujours aller au delà mais
il faut toujours que ça aille dans le
sens de la créativité et voilà de
quelque chose de vrai de sincère voilà
je vous remercie d'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]